[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys somehow we got lucky enough
to get mr bobby kim aka bobby hundreds
on the show today wow what a legend
he used to be bobby thousands before
crypto crashed
but after crypto
did you
crash hard on crypto because i know
you're heavily involved of course i
think anyone who had crypto if you had
it harder than us
[Laughter]
uh i mean i guess if you no matter if
you slice it and dice it straight away
yeah for sure i've definitely
what about us combined it's over over
two
guess how much fun we had not that much
fun
and you know what's even better this is
the second time we did it that's right
because we said the first time we're
gonna cash out right what was it like
are you saying 2017 first time no first
time
yeah yeah yeah around that time
this is a part of it
what were you that death is a part of
life that's true what were you holding
that now you what were you like really
pridefully holding that you now regret
nfg wise anything in this room oh see he
went to nft first that's so that's scary
that's a scary answer well because i've
been into crypto since 2017 but i think
because of nfts i went much deeper
but um i actually don't i mean there are
some really shitty jpegs you know bad
nfg projects that
i and i don't want to
are there any good jpegs i guess is my
whole thing i think so okay i think so
and i guess i guess it also depends on
how you want to look in are they art to
you are they collectibles and they're
fun novelty things or were they actually
investments like stocks and there were
bad investments but most of my nfts i
never looked at as investments it was
more like i just like having them in my
wallet because either they have a
utility or it's a membership to some
community or club usually that's the
utility or yeah the remember just the
dow it's just like vibes also yeah
or it's just like cool art there's some
of it that i just like there's like an
uh an artist named jujeban he's a south
korean artist and
i collect some of his nfts just because
i like his art what do you think about
that i think my son can draw better than
that uh i think that's very valid and it
has you know when you actually get into
art and you realize much of it doesn't
actually have to do with technical
prowess or skills this problem is his
son will draw it on his [ __ ] computer
screen and bar will cry because it's so
beautiful i'm sure it is permanent
marker that means something you know and
so when you start trying to quantify and
put money value financial value on art
it's complicated because now you're
mixing emotions with and sentimental
value with and there's a tax tax hiding
aspect of it that rich people play like
that like the art community in general
that's always been a big part of heart
so it's like is it really worth that
much or is it because their friend said
it's that much and now they need to
write it off yep that's
definitely part of the game as well
what's your favorite nft project do you
have a favorite there's a project called
lit that i think is really smart and all
you could have said was pretty lit i
thought you're good i mean it is very
lit they
i think they named it the entire project
ironically just to throw people off the
trail a bit but when you get into the
different projects they do they're
really smart and and
they're intelligent there's um what's
hard about that what do they do yeah
they just uh there's a project they did
with robert de niro where uh the nft
changes his face facial expression he
makes different faces every time you
check it
depending on where ethereum is in the
marketplace so if ethereum's falling off
a crash like it's been doing the last
couple of days so he's like he's like
he's literally he just went down a
little bit it went down a little bit
yeah a little bit
does he ever smile i've never seen him
smiling anything yeah
he does he does do a smile every now and
then in his later films i don't think i
remember zac efron once every four years
according to the graph yeah yeah yeah
exactly so before people think that
bobby is a crypto god i'm not i'm
definitely not we should don't listen to
me
crypto gods have fallen bro yes
we should go into a little bit of a
history of
why people know about like bobby because
like um i know you uh from clothing in
the in the fashion world clothing
clothing clothing how did they drop that
g
is that how you came up i came up in
clothing in fashion yeah and i'm wearing
his brand wow i think the hundreds
wow you should be our lookbook model
thank you i wish i will that was joking
i won't even charge i won't even charge
it yeah i know i've been discovered
today i got a big laugh out there
actually we do get a lot of those
messages from kids saying i will model
for you for free and i'm like why would
we want you to model for us it's gonna
cost you yeah that actually costs us
that's enough do you guys get this i'll
come work for you for free yeah and i'm
like do you know i'm giving you i'm
training you for free that's what it
sounds like you know like why would i do
that that's like the thing now they're
they're like um it's like it's like when
they watch those hustler videos they're
like you know what you gotta do is you
gotta learn how to work for free man and
then when you work for free then you
just [ __ ] learn honesty or
new thing too though is that they'll do
that first thing where they're like hey
i want to work for you from [ __ ]
hustle and then they'll watch like uh
some tick tock video like like two days
into working for you where it's like if
you're working for free you're getting
ripped off and like yeah i'm getting
[ __ ] scared
it's a two-day turnaround
so much conflicting con you know i need
to get a paycheck man i'm not respecting
myself
but you get a good two days of free work
yeah yeah yeah yeah the best wardrobe
that's hilarious dude
um yeah i mean but i got into fashion
and speaking of arts i think i was an
artist first as early as i remember i
was drawing i was attracted to the arts
and i never thought i could make a
living doing that just because i was
conditioned from my parents and my
korean immigrant parents and my teachers
and people in my neighborhood that were
like you're never going to make a living
being an artist even my school counselor
i remember she's just like no you should
definitely not go down this path
it's hopeless and i think that was kind
of the logic at that time i grew up in
the 80s and the 90s and there just
weren't a lot of
inspirational role model stories of kids
making it being an artist and like
building successful careers and being
entrepreneurial but our generation did
that right like we figured out how to
make businesses and thriving economies
work around
uh your passions and like being creative
and artistic and that just that wasn't
the case yeah i would you have a did you
have korean parents that whipped your
ass
what my ass almost every other day yeah
do you pass on that that lovely korean
tradition i do not
it was so
traumatic and i've been unearthing so
much trauma for the last 30 40 years
through deep therapy just to get out of
that mess did your parents ever rip up
your illustrations when you were kids i
didn't they didn't rip them up because
they didn't know i was doing it because
i had a high
drawing you have to hide the drawings
yeah most a lot of kids childhoods at
that time where you were hiding under
your covers reading playboys or you know
like under your bed and your parents
were like where are you and you're like
looking at hustlers you just got it with
charcoal pencils i literally was
disappearing ink i would have drawing
naked women that's what good
you'd have i'd have to like listen you
know like like like you're watching porn
you have to be like really like
sensitive to like is someone coming down
the hall you know but i was doing that
for drawing like i was just like someone
coming down the looking at the door
every two years exactly just like he's
like a prisoner that can't have couldn't
draw you can't so wrong think
that's how much it meant to me when i
was finally able to draw for a living
and it was liberating it was i was
actually making money drawing and then
at that that was people asked me what
was the moment that i knew i made it and
i'm like that was probably the happiest
day of my career and i was like just
starting i was we were making enough
money to pay them rent and then i was
like i can draw forever and that's all
about that so all your first designs
yes for for many years actually the
first
several seasons of the hundreds i
designed almost everything head to toe
all the cut and so to graphic t-shirts
beanies and headwear everything yeah and
it fit in a fit of irony have you ever
drawn your parents and then given it to
them
and then signed that [ __ ] in the bottom
right no no i haven't but i don't know
if that would go over well and it just i
don't think i'd be able to capture them
right people don't like when i draw them
this is also something that do you do
that often experience well you know when
you're an artist everyone always says
like draw me draw me you know you do a
character from me wearing this only this
you know like kate winslet
yeah that happens all the time it
happens all the time and then you're
like immediately are you sure and then
you do it and they're like i don't look
like and you're like you asked me to
draw you this is how i see you yeah this
is how i see you and it's the same with
a lot of designers like um a lot of
graphic designers get asked to design
their friends logos for brands and stuff
do my logo and you're like you sure you
want me to do your yeah i want you to do
my logo however you think it looks best
and then you design it and then all of a
sudden they have input because
everyone's a designer these days right
you never tell them you told me to do
this shut the [ __ ] up that's what
happens
so it's a very tortured relationship for
an artist when you were when when you
were like collabing with all those early
brands that were getting office space in
your guys's headquarters yeah were you
also doing illustrations for those
brands um if there were certain no no uh
if we're partnering with certain brands
or we're working alongside them we want
them to do what they do best and we do
the same thing in terms of when we have
freelancers or outside artists that are
contributing artwork for collaborations
or clothing a lot of times they're like
tell us what you want us to do and i'm
like no we came to you because we want
you to do what you do what brands are in
your headquarters i can't really say but
we do partner yeah it's all like
confidential but we do
can you say who you've worked with in
the past i mean there are a lot of
brands that we've collaborated with in
the past and that we support right and
we have nothing to do with zhang but
like hujungu is like a really popular
young uh korean american run brand right
now coming up in streetwear so jung's
popular which i would definitely check
out wjw
in the timeline of the stuff you
accomplished did you finish law school
yeah four
we graduated yes we graduated law school
we started uh the hundreds in our after
our first year of law school law school
is three years both him and his partners
both my partner ben and i and uh yeah we
met each other in the midst of that
first year
by the end of the first year we're like
let's try doing this over the summer and
i had no intentions of turning this into
an actual company i just was i just i
felt really
i guess
uncreative like i wasn't you know i was
restricted from pursuing any kind of
passion because of law school and i'd
put myself in that position more or less
but it's just a very dry place it's you
know it's it's you're trying to be a
good asian yeah i was trying to be good
asian i was also like i had good
intentions going to law school i was
coming off of being an artist and a
writer for many years and just wasn't
working 9 11 had happened and you know a
lot of that kind of some of us disagree
[Laughter]
oh right with the 9 11 thing sure that's
fine i don't even think it happened bro
is all cg huh i don't think it happened
the date september 11th actually
happened i don't i don't i don't think
that it did yeah
i remember
happening again in a few days
i'm actually flying on that day me too
yeah to commemorate
she's not going anywhere if you had to
sit down and pitch somebody like what
your company exactly is for new people
who don't know you like oh gosh that's
that's
yeah that question has become so
impossible to answer don't you all find
that question just difficult to answer
is it because the more you've expanded
the more things you do or what is it
yeah there's just and there's more
curious and interest and you know it
depends on also where my money is it's
like where's my money coming from i
don't know that's like in investments
and like property and credit if you have
to describe
the hundreds then
and three animals yes
in three animals three animals um
it would be soft like a bengal tiger
because of apparel i guess
i mean at its core where a streetwear
brand yeah like this kind of tiger
uh yeah
i had a question if that was real or not
what do you think it's a real white
tiger the universe is fake anyway dude
trust me it's really fake yeah yeah um
no it looks it doesn't matter actually
it looks sick right is it real to you
everything everything is a myth and a
narrative so if that's what you're
saying then i believe it i don't care
either way that's that's our street
right here
he's our influence he went from full
american to eastern european yeah i'm an
icon he's russian for sure if i ran to
you on the street
i would think that you're eastern
european i thought you're gonna say i
throw hands immediately
and that was the second part
why would i do that have you had that
man i caught myself in the mirror this
morning and i wanted to throw hands and
i was like whoa whoa that's us that's
like okay okay oh my god no
do people often say that to you
it's a new rebrand for me and uh
i'm honestly not used to it and i want
to
constantly punch myself in the face the
last couple months he's been coming in
with like crazy outfits
it's a rebrand a rebrand
yeah do you usually look like a 48 year
old dad yeah are you 48 years old i'm
not okay yes okay well i would never
guess no i'm not a dad
no it was a 48 year old dad on his first
vacation to the grand canyon that was
his style yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's a 25 year old eastern european guy
exactly that works i'm getting that that
message is coming through loud and clear
this is a new flavor though today
eastern europe well there's so many
zippers i don't even know what the
[ __ ] going on
just more pockets really yeah did you
see my keys in my wallet that's utility
what do you search to find these things
online uh punchable faces
what was it about uh art that your
parents didn't like you doing it i i
just think that was the narrative
speaking of narratives that was the
narrative at the time you know your
parents
for those of us who had immigrant
parents especially for second generation
that were coming here they sacrificed
everything so that their kids could
pursue this career of becoming a
professional or a doctor to you know
government person or whatever it is and
then you're like no i'm gonna sit in the
corner of the room and draw pictures
there really weren't not many examples
of that in the in that period of time
you just thought it was like a waste of
time like i came all the way over here
for you to do this yeah you know the
entrepreneurial spirit definitely wasn't
that deeply rooted back then i was
watching forrest gump this is kind of a
dumb story but this
it makes it'll make sense in the end i
was watching forrest gump this weekend
with my son first of all i didn't
realize how i didn't remember how much
of that movie was a love story it's like
every five seconds it defaults back to
the jenny jenny thing and my kids were
just like rolling their eyes like what
is this wrong but i was trying to
explain them i'm like this
does that matter well i think
apparently you guys are located next to
a dentist
they're coming for our gold bars
that that movie is a cross-section of
american history right so i was
explaining every decade i'm like the 50s
were about 60s there was war and like
political turmoil and then like the 70s
hippie movement right and i was like the
80s i would fall asleep if i heard all
that too right exactly and like half of
them i think watching a movie with my
dad sucks
but then in the eight the 80s was about
like american exceptionalism and
capitalism right where people and so
like that was the chapter of the movie
where they talk about nike and then he
makes like the have a nice day shirt and
it's all about these like starting up
brands and then he builds bubba gupp
right and so that was like to me i think
that's what they're saying like they're
like this is what the 80s are about and
so but before that you didn't have that
as a part of american history it was
just like here's your career path and
this is what you follow right like
you're a gm guy you work at gm for 80
years you get a gold watch like that's
what you do and you just you shut your
mouth about it so all our immigrant
parents coming here were like we're just
grateful to be here keep our head down
so nobody notices us let's just lock in
a profession and just like just keep our
mouths shut you know and then i'm coming
around like no i want to be this i want
to be you know i want to be an artist or
i want to start a skateboard company
which is what i wanted to do when i was
growing up and my parents were like no
no that's never been done before
thankfully like we all did that over the
last two decades where our kids are like
i can do anything now right they're
watching bart being like i want to be
just like bart no way fitness influencer
fitness guru
strong and handsome
so now that you're is there like uh
anything that you want your kid to be or
even hope that he does
anything he wants to do uh you know i
hope that we can all figure out how to
make it work together um he'll figure it
out they'll figure it out on their own
there's two boys but i've always told
them do whatever you want to do as long
as you're happy and passionate about
doing it we'll figure out a way what if
their goal in life was to be lazy well i
even that i feel like we can somehow
turn into because i think my children
are very lazy i'm incredibly lazy and i
think most of us who work really hard
are actually lazy like i work so much
just so that i can lay down as much as
possible
right just like how much time can i lock
can i build into my day to lay down and
so it's just like if i hire more people
to do that job then i can lay down a
little bit longer and then you have more
inspiration to do more dream [ __ ] yeah
and you're like wait it's gonna take
work to achieve these dreams and then so
i gotta get up and like right it forces
me so there is i think an exchange there
because a lot of the hard-working people
i know they don't actually get that far
they they do good working for other
people right they like are good as staff
and employees and like they have like a
really successful career like that but i
think a lot of founders and owners and
like startup people are actually pretty
lazy they aren't good working for other
like i was the worst employee at every
job that i had before i started the
hundreds i just was like literally
falling asleep on my desk and all my
internships and i worked for the city
attorney for a whole summer and
literally my boss would come out funny
like literally sleeping on the desk and
i was just like i gotta figure it out
away
i was just sitting there drawing one
time and i was like i gotta figure out a
way to work for myself so that i can
sleep all the time wow that's the secret
of business that's the secret but isn't
that kind of like working for other
people it kind of does make you feel
lazy because it's like you don't get to
necessarily reap the rewards unless
they're here somewhere that's structured
really nice right like usually usually
it's like yeah i'm working for somebody
else so i can get to where the point
where i can make my own thing if that's
what your mindset is yeah that's a
conversation i have a lot especially the
last couple of years as more and more
people are going through this crisis or
just having these breakthrough moments
of do i want to work at a company or do
i want to work for myself do you want to
work from home do i want to go to an
office and i've been having this a lot
with staff that have been coming in and
out too because i think the pandemic
just forced a lot of people to reckon to
to reckon with do i want to stay in the
same building for the rest of my life
and work for somebody else do i want to
pursue my dreams and i think there's
actually a beauty to both a lot of
people who are employees or work for
someone else they want to be founders
because they look at that as freedom and
i'm always just like are you kidding me
like i wish i could be like you i wish
that i had the wherewithal and the
passion to be able to work for a company
and a team and like i've just never been
a good team player growing up i couldn't
do any team sports were not for me i had
to do individual sports and the same
thing with companies i didn't know how
to work with other people that's why i
became a founder but for me when i'm
looking at my staff leaving every day at
5 5 30 p.m and they go home they have
they can pursue their own lives and
their own interests and they have side
hustles whatever i'm like man that's
freedom like i'll never be able to do
that right they can turn it off we know
this as entrepreneurs is that you're 25
hours a day dedicated one thing you
can't do things that you really want to
do right everyone's like oh you can
you're following your dreams i'm like
all i
these are my dreams i'll never be able
to pursue them because i'm so committed
to this i have overhead and i have my
staff that i have
responsibilities and you know duties and
like i can't go off and just explore
whatever i want to do all the time which
is a skateboarding company let's just
make it right now she just started we'll
incorporate it online get get the laptop
i'll show you how to do it okay you got
your models over there the fashion icons
yeah pull up legals in your mind
[Laughter]
oh we gotta buy a bunch of wheels and
wood
this is probably the easiest business
ever what's a two by four i love
diminishing that it's hilarious i don't
know if uh how sustainable skateboard
company with six owners is gonna be
no we'll figure it out
thin slice of pie now that we're getting
one six of the board yeah
he just wants to chill all day so we
know he's not going to be too involved
now that uh a lot of people look to you
for like the blueprint of how to do this
yeah and there
there could be people out there that are
like you know what i'm not going to be a
dealer i'm not going to be a lawyer i
want to do what you do right how do you
what's your best way of explaining hey
man this isn't easy either you know like
because people i think if you read my
book yeah yeah when i wrote what's your
book called it's called this is not a
t-shirt it's my memoir and it's the
story of my life and how we built the
brand but when i wrote it everyone
expected it to be oh it's your success
story and all your wins and victories
and i was like it's actually a failure
story it's just like all about hardships
and how we kept messing up over and over
and over again and how to pick ourselves
up adapt and pivot which is every day in
this game especially every type of
business now you have to reinvent
yourself every single day just to keep
your head above water just to stay
relevant and things are moving so fast
and so when you read that book i think
it's a pretty honest depiction of what
it's like it's not this massive
corporation we're still a mom and pop
shop every single day like i still run
the business like it's day one like we
don't have any backers or investors in
the in the company we've never had
and so um i think it might be helpful to
read that and also just talk to other
people who are founders and understand
how hard it is the grass is always
greener on the other side i would love
to be a staff person somewhere at a
company be a part of a team that's you
know like i think there's something
really noble in that in everyone working
together to build something and if
something ever goes wrong with that
company or brand you can perish you can
rip cord and pull right out of that and
start your other dream right i'll never
be able to do that and forever tethered
to my company no matter what it does i
could sell my company today in 30 years
people are still gonna be like you're
the guy from the hundreds right that
failed it and that failed it or even if
it's you'll never make a skateboarding
company you're a loser
even if it's successful like that will
always eclipse whatever else i do all
right i can start like the world's best
coffee company tomorrow and people are
still gonna be like
marky mark i remember when you were
dancing around in your underwear and
this was like yeah i'm a very successful
actor now and it's like i'm mark
wahlberg no for me you're calvin klein
modeled marky mark forever right and so
these are things that you always have to
think about it's just it's not always
what it seems to be to be like a founder
owner everyone wants that i understand
they think and they also think there's
more money in it that's also the other
myth and mirage of the whole things
people always like because when i say
this i always say like you don't you can
also always not start a brand you can
also always not start your own company
you know you get your dream can be also
working with some other people but
they're like oh you're just trying to
like keep all the money for yourself and
you're trying to hold others down i'm
like i make less money than some of my
employees right and in the long run like
i lose a lot more money than people like
people can save and invest in like i'm
constantly pouring all my life savings
back into this work there are months
where i have to skip paying myself just
to pay the rent and like keep the lights
on and people don't see that part dang
this guy's not a very good businessman
[Music]
here
[Music]